how are you doing this I am going to
choose out of these two right I'm going
to choose one of them to be you and I'm
going to choose the other one to be DVM
DX it has to be DB or DX because do you
notice is no DX here so to compensate
for this DX it's there I have to divide
through my tears okay so I want one of
these to be you and one of them to be DV
on DX now there's a good choice and
there's a poor choice and that's part of
why this is not just a rule
you can't just blindly do this you have
to have to think more which ones which
for the regular product or what you end
up with is symmetrical in you and B so
whichever right but here you have to be
careful okay so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to run sort of just be easy on
you I'm gonna tell you which ones which
and then we'll see after we finish this
question what happens when you choose
them poorly okay so I'm going to call
this one you and I'm gonna call this one
DV on DX okay so once you've done this
here's the way I like to set it out
there's lots of different ways to set
this out but on the right hand side in
the same way that on the right hand side
I usually put my information in that
substitutions and so on what I'm looking
for is two primitives and two
derivatives okay so I'm looking for a
you V do you on decks and a DV DX okay
so these feel part of what make up
integration by parts I'm going to take
once I've worked out all four of these
I'm going to put them into here and then
see what emerges out the other side now
like I said before I've just chosen for
you which ones you and which ones DV m
DX so if I say this one is U then that
tells you what do you and the excellence
here's what I'm to find the other one to
be DV on DX and again for the second
Queens I'm not worried about constants
of integration
yeah to get from devient DX to V I have
to integrate right so what's the
primitive function of cos x just so okay
so I've got all my parts there huh this
is the integral of UDV
this is the left hand side so now I'm
going to write the right hand side okay
I've got all of this together in a box
what I'm fault well what is UV it's
exciting so this is X X that's the new
vapor and you subtract the integral of V
times D on the X DX so take away and you
can see here this is where V do you
comes from that diagonal is critically
important as I'll show you in a second
okay so what am I actually integrating
it's V which is sine x times what what
is the EU in this case it's just 1 right
with respect to X is that okay all right
so I've already gotten X sine X out the
front take away what's the integral of
sine X negative cos right and there's a
negative at the front here too so they
are cancel that and now because all my
integrals are going down there by my
customer division so this is the answer
I've got how will we know whether we got
the right answer or just let's just
appreciate okay so down the bottom here
let's all do this because three let's
just
[Music]
I'm gonna leave off the coast a because
it doesn't matter in this context what's
the dude of X sine X remember I've got a
product to you you and me what are you
gonna help me right off the dash plus
you V - yep
and then this this guy which is minus
sine X right cancel cancel it works it
works it's always magic right like
you've made this choice and then you
just substitute the pots in and then
that leaves the odd song almost without
even thinking it's kind of weird now
you remember I said to you before here
you have to choose you got to choose
suppose you didn't make this choice from
the beginning by the way you don't even
know what what criteria should I use for
choosing well I'm not to show you
suppose let's just restart the whole
question okay yeah yeah you see okay so
I'm gonna try it again X cos x DX and
this time I'm going to reverse my order
so what if I said well let's make that
one you and let's make this one DV DX
yeah I'm gonna try again I'm looking for
two primitives and two derivatives okay
so I've let u equal cos x and I've let
DV on DX equal X yeah what's the
derivative over here yeah and what
x squared on to okay now it doesn't look
immediately obvious why this is a
problem but as soon as I write the next
line actually substitute my parts into
here suddenly it's action effects watch
the integral of U DV is times V yep -
right
minus the integral of V which is x
squared - x GU which is minus sine X DX
now you look at that and you're like
what wait what happened
this is worse than what I started with
okay
so therefore now you can see I told you
to choose at least mercifully there's
only really two choices here so it's
like well if you get it wrong the first
time that you get to this point here to
this point say oh no no no it's not
gonna work so then you try the other one
but what is it about this that is sort
of problematic which will guide your
choice in the future yeah okay so
choosing excess DV DX that led me to
this the V right but V it needs to be
integrated right eventually now that's
not so hot on its own X we know - is
fine
ah but remember how I said this green
error was gonna be really important
before you need to pay close attention
to what that's going to be because
that's what guides you whether you
choose one or the other okay here's what
I'm gonna ask you to write down okay we
must choose U and V and this is not the
only criteria but is the most important
criterion but is the most important one
such that now where's the arrow going
between its v md u right that's the
thing that has to be integrated
and this time of sine X super easy this
time we got next grade on 2 sine X Y
alright so you want to choose U and V
such that V do you I'm sorry can you add
D me on the answer such that V D u is
easy to Internet and that's what you're
after
okay so you can see this is why it's
part of why it's not just called the
reverse product rule it's not like oh
okay
I'm just going to put the pieces in you
actually have to be a little bit
thoughtful about it and you can use it
wrongly it just stopped